あの 大体この仏教の話っていうのは
我々はよく知ってるんだというふうな気持ちはあるかもしれませんだけど
そういう知ってるんだという気持ちでいても
なかなか普通の知識では理解できるぐらいのものではないと思いますけど
特に難しいのは 別に理解は難しくはないんです
すごくもう 何も固定観なく
まあただ聞いておけばわかるもんなんですけど
ずっと自分たちが持っているいろんな概念から解釈しようとしているんですね
それだけだったら もうそれだったらもう全くわからなくなるんですね
自分たちが今すでに持っているいろんな考え方やら世間観やら人生観とか宗教観とか
そういうものはもう当然人間ですからいろいろあるんだけど
その枠から解釈しようとしても
それは無理なんです どんなものでもちゃんと勉強したいと思うならば
他の考え方は一時的にでも置いておいた方がいいんです
そうするとすごく早くわかるんです
私も昔から勉強するときは
大体そういうふうに勉強するんです
決して仏教のものだと思って
他のものを勉強するときは
その仏教の価値観から角度からものを見ようとはしないんです
その 例えばキリスト教を勉強するときは
そのキリスト教の方々はどういう角度で説明しているんですかと
それはその通りに読んだり勉強したりするし
そうするとかなり早く理解できるんですね
理解した上で それから自分の判断と対照したっても
批判したっても 比べたっても
それは別なことで それはそれで構いませんですけど
最初には私はそう思ってるんだからということで考えると困るんですね
で なんでこういうことを初めから言ったんですかというと
どうしても人間はもう霊魂あるいは魂と
あるいは人が死んでも何か死なない何かものがあるんだと
そういうふうなこの概念があるんですね
その概念はもうもうあってもなくても
私には別に関係ないんだけど
他のことを説明しようとするときでも
どうしてもその概念は持ってくるんですね
それで解釈しようとしているんですね
それで困るんです まず仏教で言っていることを聞いてから
理解してから そういう概念と比べても構いませんし
そういうことで かなり私は精神的にも困るところはあるんですね
人間というのはすごく我々はもうなんだかんだでも知ってるぞという気持ちで質問するんだけど
どうも私の頭ではそんなに質問するたびに説明することはできないんですね
これは何だ あれは何だとかね
もし相手が固定観念がなくて
本当に知りたいと この者は何を言いたがっているんですか？という気持ちで聞いているならば
何かわかるんですけどね
なかなかそうは聞かないんですね
そうは聞いてくれないし
それでいろいろ困るところはありますけど
とにかく今日はこの 因縁の話に戻りますので
今日初めていらっしゃっている方々がいるならば
ちょっと紹介として一言言いますけど
この因縁という言葉は日本語ですけど
その言葉を聞いた途端
日本語で言ってる因縁と思いますけど
あの 英語だったらこの causation という言葉がありまして
で この 2つの言葉がございまして
コーセーションあるいはコーシティ
そういえばなかなか辞書を引かなきゃわかりませんと思うかもしれませんだけど cause
という これCA言うかちょっと
あのcauseという言葉はみんな大体結構知ってるんですね
それもわかりませんというならば
これにBE入れてみてください
そうすると大体みんな知ってるんですね BE
入れたら知ってるでしょ because
で becauseというのはなぜならという日本語の意味なんですね
そのBというのは be動詞のbeで
で これを消しちゃったらcauseなるんですね cause
というのは理由 なぜという理由なんですね
原因 それで causalityといえば
まあちょっと難しい意味になりますけど causation
と元に戻りますけど やっぱりこの
そういう原因関係 因縁
因縁関係を教えるという意味なんですね Causation
といえば その法則なんですね
因縁関係 因縁という法則という意味なんです causality
というのは それはちょっと哲学っぽい言葉で
物事は物事のこの因縁によって生まれるということを説明するという意味なんですね
適切な日本語の言葉は思い浮かびませんので
それなりにお考えになってください
とにかく英語の言葉でも
英語の言葉でわかった方がいくらか固定観念は入らないかもしれません
因縁 因縁と言った途端
まあこの日本で一般的に言ってるごく普通なくだらない因縁という概念に入っちゃうんですね
因がありましたとかね
これもなんとか因縁ではないかとかね
で そういう意味で取ってもらったらもう困るし
だからってそれは全く違うということを私は言ってるわけではないんです
それは我々 ごく普通の会話で
日常会話で使っている言葉で
この日常会話で まあご飯食べておせんべい食べながら喋ってる
もう普通の会話で使っている
これも因縁だからということをもって仏教の因果論を理解しようとするのは
あまりにも乱暴で失礼なんですね
そんなとんでもない野蛮なことをしてほしくないんです
我々 そんなお釈迦様あるいは他の古い
いろんな仏教の あの昔の先生たちが考えたように高度な哲学
日常茶飯事に喋っているわけじゃないでしょうに
明日何食べるかとかね
電車が何時にあるんですかとかね
それぐらいのことですからね
普通 日常で食卓で喋っているのは
今日は寒いですねとか
それでなんとか それも因縁ですねとか言ってしまっちゃうし
それぐらいの意味で まあ仏教は因縁の話かと
そういうふうな軽い気持ちで聞いているならば
私それはとんでもないことをしてしまうんです
で できるだけ簡単に説明しようと思ってますから
そういう気持ちを抑えておいて
一応聞いてみましょう
で 因縁というのは causality
っていうのは この仏教と他の宗教比べてみると
仏教と他の宗教と哲学と科学
全部混ぜてみてみましょう
で 我々はいろんなものを説明しようとしているんですね
で キリスト教の聖書は読んでみてください
これはどうやってこの人間の世界が現れたんですかと
人間がなぜ苦しんでいるんですかと
人間はどう生きるべきですかということを聖書で説明しているんですね
で コーランという本を取ってみたっても
同じこと同じことを言ってるんですね
同じことっていうのは
人間はどうやってこの世の中で現れたんですかと
なぜ人間がいろいろ苦しみを感じているんですかと
それから人間はどう生きるべきですかということを説明しようとしているんですね
でも コーランの教えと聖書の教えはいろんな面では違うんです
で インドの他の宗教の本がいろいろありまして
私が知っているのはヒンドゥー教のいくらかテキストなんですけど
で そこら辺見たっても
まあどうやってこの世の中生まれて現れてきたんですかと
なぜ人間が苦しんでいるんですかと
人間はどうすればいいんですかということを説明しているんですね
そこで科学という世界はどういうことかというと
それももうこの世の中はどういうものかと
どういうふうに成り立っているんですかという部分は
科学の世界でも考えているんですね
次の半分は科学ではないんです
人間はどう生きるべきかと
人間はなぜ苦しみかと
どう生きるべきかという半分は科学ではないんです
で だから半分はあるんですね
でも我々は普通 もう科学の世界の方が素晴らしいんではないかと
仏教 宗教よりは大変素晴らしい
いいものではないかと思う場合もあるかもしれませんだけど
でも科学では決して生き方を教えてくれないんですね
それは科学の分野じゃないんです
嘘をつくなとかね 嫉妬するなとか喧嘩するなとかね
それは科学の世界じゃない
それを代わりによく喧嘩しなさいと
どうやれば自分が安全なところにいて
大勢の人は殺すんですかという
そういうのは科学の世界なんです
いわゆる生き方に対して別に何も言ってはないんですね
ですから 我々から見れば
科学っていうのは知識の半分だけなんですね
どうやってこの世の中はこういう風にありますかということの説明だけなんですね
そこでそちらもいろいろからくりをやって
冬はなぜ寒いですかと研究してたところで
じゃあその寒さはどうやってなくしますかと寒さをなくそうとしてるんですね
それで暖房を作ったりするんですね
その代わりに人間の生き方を何とかしようと思わないんですね
宗教だったら もう寒さ
暑さにいちいち文句を言うなと
しっかりしなさいとぐらいでも言ってるんですね
ですから 暖房を作る必要はなくなっちゃうんですね
暖房を作ってあげてだったら
寒さに泣いている人々に対して暖房を作ってあげるんですね
暑さに泣いている人々に対しては冷房を作ってあげちゃうんです
いわゆる弱い者に 宗教はしっかりしなさいと
暑いだから泣くは 寒いだから泣くは
お腹が減っただから泣くは
お腹が満腹になっただからと泣くと
なんだかんだも泣きっぱなしでどうですかと
そろそろ泣きっぱなしで終わりますから
しっかりしなさいと しっかりしなさいと言うんだから
まあキリスト教教会でも暖房の開発も冷房の開発もしてないんです
仏教の世界でもそんなことはやってないんです
それは科学でやってるものなんですね
例えば いろんな遠いところへ行きたい
もう行けないんだと 泣いたりすると
科学者は車やら自動車やらいろいろものを作ったりするんだけどね
宗教だったら あなたはこっちへ行っても落ち着きがないし
そこであそこ行きたいと思っちゃうし
あそこ行っちゃったら
そこでも気が済む まあ何て言いますか
気が済まないんだから
また他のところに行きたがっちゃうし
こっちで満足して生きていられないあなたは
あっち行っても同じこと
こっち行っても同じことだと
だからしっかりしなさいと
いるところできちんと堂々と生きているように心を強くしなさいと宗教は言ってるんですね
ですから 宗教ではバスも車も電車も作れないんですね
作る必要はなくなっちゃうんですね
そういう差はあるんですね
宗教と科学のでは だから科学はどこまで勉強したっても
人間は原始的な状態でそのまんまなんです
発展はしない でも科学の人々は人間は素晴らしく発展しているんですよと思ってるんですね
でも宗教から言うのは
いえ 物質はいろいろからくりをしているんだと
いろんな物質のからくりですね
そういうのは いろいろおもちゃいっぱい作ってるんですね
おもちゃが増えるだけ
いわゆるゴミ箱が増えるだけで
人間はそのまんまなんですね
ですから 科学だけあったら人間の進化は止まるんです
科学発展する以前に 人間はかなり強烈に進化していたんですね
それは科学と同時にどんどんどんどん進化を止めて
退化するようになってるんですね
それをわからないいろんな人々は
もう素晴らしく今は進化しているんだと思ってるんですけど
変化しているんですけどね
毎日毎日変化はあるんですね
この変化は心の変化でもないんです
体の変化でもないんです
外のものの変化なんですね
ものの変化はあるんです
ですから 宗教ではものの変化ではなくて
心の変化を考えているんですね
ですから 一番いいのは
その二人が手を合わせることなんですね
科学の世界と宗教の世界
手を合わせたら まあ物の変化もあるし
心の進化もあるし そうするとより素晴らしい結果が得られるかもしれませんだけど
どうもあの あまりうまくいかないんですね
宗教家と科学はもう対立しているような感じもするんです
で 仏教という教えは 決して科学には対立しないんです
で 科学は素晴らしいとも思ってないんだけど
まあそれ まあその分役に立ってるんじゃないかと
まあそれぐらいは認めているし
で かなりうまく一緒に生きることはできるんですね
それできるポイントはどこにありますかというと
このコーセーションなんですね
コーサリティーなんですね
物事はそれなりの因縁があって
原因があって 条件があって変わるんだと
物事はいつでも変わっていくんだと
その変わっているためには
それなりの十分な理由があるんだ
それからその理由もたった一つではなくて
それまた様々ですよと
例えばリンゴを一個持ってきてください
このリンゴはずっとそのまんまでいるわけじゃないんですね
瞬間瞬間変化していくんですね
それで皆様に聞いたら
なんであの どこかに机の上に置いといたリンゴ 1個が 1ヶ月間経ったら
まあ変化して食べられない状態になって腐ってしまったんですか？では何か言うかもしれません
でも簡単に皆様に説明できますか？例えばリンゴはどれぐらい持てますかね
わかりませんだけど 例えば
どこかに置いておく 冷蔵庫に入れないで
もしかすると まあ 1ヶ月はもたないんですね
一応 僕ら知ってる果物っていうのは
まあ 1日2日で腐ってしまっちゃいますけど
我々の国の果物っていうのは
こういう方のこちらの果物っていうのは
そんな簡単には悪くはなりませんしね
まあそれはそれで置いておいて
例えば 1ヶ月間でリンゴが腐ってますよと言ったら
皆様はどう説明します？それはなぜ腐りますかと
じゃあ聞きますと説明できますかと
すごく説明できると思ってるんです
例えば 腐るということも
いろんなわけがあって腐るってことが働くんですね
微生物が働くことによっての腐る
それから そのリンゴの中の酵素
分子が分解することによっても腐る
虫やらゴキブリに食われることによっても
で 腐ることはあるし あるいはリンゴの水分はどんどん飛んでいって
それによって中はね  なんの状態ですかね
なんか綿みたいにカサカサの状態になって
もう腐ると いろいろ腐り方ありますよ
じゃあそれだったら それは研究できるんだから
じゃあ皆様リンゴ 1個見て
そのリンゴはどういう風に腐るんですか？説明してください
それはできないでしょうに
どんな形で腐るかと それわからない
見てみなきゃ そういう例を言ったのは
たった我々毎日しているリンゴのコーサリティーであろうか
なかなか難しくて言えないんではないかと
リンゴは 3ヶ月間経ったら必ずしもこうなりますよと言いたがるんですよ
我々の心の中で あれはバカバカらしいと私は言いたいんです
必ずしもこうなりますよとは言えないんです
リンゴの腐り方はいろいろあるんだから
その同じリンゴを外へ置いておけばどうなるんですか？外冬を置いておけばどうなるんですか？あるいは夏
外に置いておけばどうなるんですかと
天日に干せる干して腐るように置いておけば
腐り方また違うし 地面の土の上で置いておけばまた腐り方が変わるし
土の中に入れておけばまた腐り方が変わっちゃうし
そういうふうなものなんですね
因縁というのは そのシステムは
たった一つの筋で説明しようとしないのは仏教のやり方なんです
リンゴは必ず腐りますよとは言いたくないんですね
例えば魚でも他の動物でも死んじゃったら体が腐りますよと
我々はいきなりにはそうは言わないんですね
腐る場合もあるし ミイラになる場合もあるんですね
それなんでしょうかと
じゃあ不確定ですかと
リンゴの運命っていうのは
不確定ですかね じゃないんです
不確定じゃないんですけど
このいろいろ因縁が揃って
それなりの結果が作る
リンゴの中に微生物が入ったら
1ヶ月間前にも腐ってしまっちゃう
私たちはよく食べるバナナのようなすごい早く分解するものだったら
1日2日で腐ってしまっちゃうし
そういうバナナでも冷凍庫なんかに置いておけば
もうそんなに腐ることはないし
そこでこの 必ずしもこうなりますよとは言い切れないことと
だからといってそうはなりませんとも言えない
例えば卵があるんだと
鶏の卵があって それを温めると
そうすると大体はそこを卵からは子犬が生まれるんじゃなくて
ヒヨコが生まれるんですね
それは決まってるんです
一応今はインキュベーターに入れて卵を温めているんだと
もしかするとどんな鳥が生まれてくるかな
ヘビが生まれてくるかな
それはわからないんだから
ワクワクしてるということはないんですね
その卵から出るのは やっぱりもう鶏の子供で
ヒヨコであることはもう確かなんですけど
そこで不確かなのは じゃあ確実にヒヨコが生まれるかないかということなんですね
そのヒヨコは雄鶏か雌鶏かと
何色を持っているかどうか
それはだいたい卵見てはわからない
健康な鶏になるか 病弱なものになるかと
それまたわからない 本当に生まれてくるかないかもわからない
そこら辺に不確定な部分があるんですね
いわゆる原因少々でも変えると結果が変わえてしまっちゃう
例えば あれはちゃんと温めてますけど
子供たちが遊んでいる途中で電気をスイッチを消したならば
そこで何時間も冷えてしまったと
それでまた見て これは大変だと思って
思って また電気を入れたっても
あれのショック受けて
中の卵の生命がなくなる可能性もあるんですね
そういうちょっとした原因で原因が変わると結果が変わるんですね
そういうことだから こんなむやみに
とても簡単に単純で  ２ たす ２ は ４ ですよというふうな感じで
因縁論を説明は理解はできないという立場が仏教で言ってるんですね
そういうふうな難しいんだと理解すれば
それに十分です そうすると
我々は人と人々で喧嘩したり
意見に争ったりはしないんです
どういうことかというと
例えばある人をこう言うでしょ
あの人はあんなもう生き方だったら
必ずもう素晴らしい人間になりますよと
でもあの人はあんな生き方だから
まるくでもない人間になりますよと
そういうふうに決めちゃって
決めつけて お互いに喧嘩するんですね
私の意見は正しいんだと
この夫婦喧嘩もそういうもので
自分の意見が正しいんだと
で いろんな意見は我々は持っていて
その自分持っている意見はえらい正しいんだと
いつでも思っているんです
そこで仏教でこの因縁論をいくらか説明して
こういう我々の意見はバカバカらしいんだと
そんなに大したことじゃないんだと
説明してあげたがってるんですね
いわゆる卵から鶏が生まれるんだということは
まあそこをその生まれるだろうという分だけではいいんだけど
でも必ずしも生まれますよと
とは言えないんだと どうなるかと分かったもんじゃないんだと
ですから 人は何か考え方を持っているのは
そんな考え方を持ってて
あんたはもうとんでもない人間になりますよと言って
その人に怒ったっても
何の意味もないんで その人はどうなるかと分かったもんじゃないんです
学校ですっごく真面目に勉強する生徒がいるんだと
そこであるとあらゆる希望は大人が作ったりして
これぐらい真面目に勉強するんだから
確実にその人はもう人生は成功するんだと
もう決めつけちゃって
で 決めつけたところから
その人に対する自分の態度
生き方が変わっちゃうでしょうに
それは全部嘘なんですね
ちょっとした因縁変われば
その人の先は変わってしまっちゃうんです
それなのに我々は決めつけちゃって
この人は確実に大物になるんだ
社会人として成功するんだと思ったところで
その人に対する我々の態度
アプローチ 生き方 喋り方
全て変えちゃう 変えてもその一つもその人に対しては合わないんですね
そこで喧嘩やら お互いに理解できなくなったりして
いろいろ問題が生まれてくるんですね
それはなぜ生まれてくるんですかというと
自分が決めつけて相手に対して行動を起こしたんだからなんですね
どんなに真面目な人で
子供であろうが どんなに頭がいい人であろうか
後からそれ変える変わる可能性はいくらでもあるんです
ずっと勉強できた子はある日突然全く勉強できなくなったとか
そういうのはごく普通のことなんですね
だから どんなものについても決めつけて考えることは不可能であると
次の瞬間どういうものかとわからないんだと
それはよくも理解できれば
その人こそ素晴らしい人間になるんです
誰とも喧嘩しない 誰とも対立しない
でも 一つも間違っている行動を起こさない
素晴らしい人間になっちゃうんですね
そういうわけで 因縁論をいくらか理解した方がよろしいと思います
で 今日はこの因縁のことを書いているテキストは
我々元々のテキストを持ってきましたけど
ただ見るだけですけどね
これは読もうとしたら
1ページ読むためには
僕にとっていえば大体4時間ぐらいはかかるかもしれません
説明して読む場合 僕はさっさと読めますけど
それぐらいもう 1行 1行もうかなり膨大な知恵を使って説明しなくちゃいけないんです
そこで一つの言葉がありまして
パラサメヤンアナユーハンテーナというパーリ語ですけども
書いても何の意味もないんですね
分かりませんだから ですから
小さな声で書きます パラサメヤンアナユーハンテーナ
パラサメヤンというのはいろんな人々の教えなんです
パラというのは他人の
サメヤンというのは宗教
あるいはいろいろ教えなんですね
アナユーハンテーナっていうのは攻撃しないために
他の人々の教え 考え方
他の宗教の考え方は攻撃して戦って
そんなくだらんことをしないために因果説を勉強するんだ
そういうのはいっぱい入っているんですよ
それたった一つの言葉なんです
ローマ字になると長いんだけど
まあパラサメヤンアナユーハンテーナ
今までずっと説明してたのはそういう立場なんです
この因果法則をわかると
人々の意見に対して自分が別に戦いたく
攻撃したく 腹が立ったりはしないんです
あなたは悪いんですよとは言えなくなっちゃうんです
あんた間違ってるんですよと言えなくなるんです
なんかすごい違う人間になってしまうんです
例えば我々の社会を見ると
ちょっとしたことで人をいじめたりする
もうみんな流行ってる服を着なくちゃいけないでしょうに
例えば今年は何色か分かりませんだけど
たとえ今年はブラック黒い色が流行っているならば
みんな黒い色をつけなくちゃいけないんですね
誰かがピンク色でも青色でも服を着たら
あれ あんた変ですねと言うんですね
それぐらいのことでも人をいじめたりするんです
例えばショートカットが流行っていると
みんな女性はショートカットにしなくちゃいけない
男性もないですけど 髪の毛伸ばす時期がありまして
みるみる男はすごく長い髪の毛伸びてゴムバンドで留まっておくとかね
みんな同じことをやっているんですね
そうやらない人は あれ
このあなた変ではないかと
よくも言うんですね そういうかすかなところからも
我々は人をバカにする
人をけなす 自分が正しいと思う
私は小さい時からもうそういう自分が薄毛だから
何もおしゃれも何もそういうものはできませんし
自分と一緒の同じ年の
人々は結構いろいろそれなりのいろいろおしゃれはするんですね
僕はそれを見て もうその人々をからかったりしたケースもあるんですね
あんた方おしゃれしたければ何か新しいものをしなさいと
なんでみんなやってることをやってるんですかと
例えば ある時期になると
もう男性ももう腕に何か腕輪です
なんて言いますか リストバンドみたいなものを何か着けたりする
そうすると どんな男を見ても何か一つはめてるんですね
自分がすごくおしゃれだと思っちゃうんで
それで それでみんなはめているんだから
あんたはめているだけではないかと
そうするとデザインは決まっていて
この決まってるデザインの腕輪しかはめないんですね
そうすると何がファッションですかと
僕は違うことをやるのはファッションではないかと
みんな腕輪はめているのはあんた首輪をはめたらどうですかと
そうはしない で それでその半年ぐらい経ったら
そのファッションは消えちゃう
それでみんなの腕からは腕輪はもう消えちゃうんですね
そうすると他のものに出てものは出てくる
このズボンにせても 僕は男性大人の関係で男性たちしか知りませんだけど
ズボンのへたいろいろきめ細かいファッションがあるんですね
このポケットの付け方
それでそれを決めてやったら
必ずその付け方で付けてこなきゃもう着ないんです
もう服あるにはあれはもうもうダサいだから着ませんと
ちょっとポケットの付け方が違うんだから
付けたい場合はまたそれは全部外して
また切って新しいファッションに入れ替えたりするんですね
ある日 ある時はこの後のバックポケットですか
それの付け方をまた決めた
決められたって みんなその形のもの付けてるんですね
それでまた両側のポケットのジップ入れるかないかと
また出てきてジップ入れるファッションになっちゃったら
みんなジップを入れてるんですね
なかったらあれ変ですよと
古いんです あなたと言っちゃうんです
で その話っていうのは
やっぱり小さい時からもう人間のやり方を見ていたんだから
ただ単にそれぐらいのことでも
我々は人を差別するし
そういう猿みたいにみんなやっていることをやらない人々は遅れていると思っちゃうし
かえって違う考え方もあるんですね
みんなやるんだから やるだけだから猿と同じではないかと
新しい考え方ないんだと
自分のファッションは自分で持ってないんだと
違うことをやる勇気がないんだと
とも言えるし かえってファッションが変わるたびに敏感で
それですごく感知して自分のファッションを変えるんだとも言えるし
その両方知っているならば
全く無関心になってしまうんですね
勝手にやれと やりたければ
新しいファッションを付けてるんだから
別にあなたは偉いわけでもないし
進んでいるわけでもないし
遅れているわけでもないんだと
で そういうつまらない例えを出したのは
我々の生き方の中で たとえ味噌汁の味についても喧嘩するんだから
それぐらいの弱い人間なんですね
決まってる味で作らなくちゃいけないんだと
それで日本で料理のすごいプロっていうのは
この機械みたいに全く同じ味で物を作らなくちゃいけないんです
全部ミリ単位で量って入れて料理する
それでものすごい腕 プロだと
かえって違う考え方もあるんですよ
あのお店に行って昨日ラーメン食べたんだけど
今日行って食べたらまた味が違うんだと
そういう風になったら
またそれも面白いと思いますけど
それは全くない  10年間も同じラーメン屋さんだってならば
全く同じ味なんですね
それはすごいと思ってる人もいるし
私のようなあんなものはつまらないんだと
あのお店で一回食べちゃったら
もう二度とは行きたくないんだと
もう味を知ってるんだからと
という私のような人間もいるんです
また行食べても同じ味でしょうと
決まってるんだ つまらないんだ
[咳]人間 そういうふうに物事を決める
決めつけたがる それは正しいと思う
それをもって人と戦う
それは因果法則がわからないんだからということは
仏教の考え方なんです
因果法則っていうのは
たとえ卵みたっても これからは確実にヒヨコが生まれますよというふうに言えないんだと
そんな証拠はないんだと
じゃあ科学者に聞いてみてください
卵を持って行って 先生
この卵から確実にヒヨコヒヨコが生まれてくると
ちゃんと何と言いますか
判子を押してくださいと言ったら断りますよ
じゃあ お医者さんのところに行って聞いてください
先生 先生の薬飲んだら
はっきりと確実に私の病気が治りますと
ちゃんとまず証明してください
いわゆる証明書を出してくださいと
もしかすると追い出されるかもしれません
他の病院行きなさいと
そんなことないんです
ただ 薬飲んだんだからって言って
必ずしも病気治るぞと
そういうことはない それは因果法則なんです
治らないわけでもないんです
例えば お腹が壊したところで
いろんな薬を売ってるんでしょうに
そういう薬飲んだら全くお腹の病気は治りませんよと
ならば薬にはなりませんだから
そうすると売れませんだから
全く治らないわけでもないんだけど
必ずしも治るってことでもないんです
治るだろうというぐらいなんですね
いわゆる可能性しかないんですね
原因変えちゃったらまあどうしようもないんです
たとえ胃の薬飲んでも
お腹の中で自分がまたその胃の薬の効き目が消える何か持っているならば
あるいはあの風邪薬とかお茶とか一緒に飲んじゃったら
風邪治るところが体にすごい悪いだけなんですね
毒になってしまうんですね
それでみんな風邪薬お茶で飲むでしょう
それで飲むわ飲むわ飲むわ
体も治らないし 私はそれを知ってるんだから
たまに風邪薬は飲む場合もありますけど
今度も二錠ぐらい三錠ぐらい飲みましたけど
三回 でもそれはちゃんと一個飲んで
ちゃんと水を飲んで それから時間
そのお腹の中でその薬ある時間は何も飲まないでっているんです
他のものとは組み合わせないように
それですいぶん少ない薬ですぐ風邪はもう治ってしまっちゃうんですね
一回薬買ったら年間使えるんです
年は薬はそこまでは持てませんだけど
だからもったいないんだから
お金は できれば誰かからちょっと薬一錠ぐらい貸してくれませんかと
一錠ぐらいで僕は十分なんです
それはちゃんと因果法則にのっとって使うんです
他の薬とは合わせませんし
まあそれはそれで ですから
このたとえ薬飲んだっての病気治るということはないし
ですから たとえ人が勉強するんだからといって頭がいい人間になると
そんなことも決められませんし
すごいシェフだから必ずしもいい料理作るということもないんです
彼にもできない時はあるんです
どんなこの野球の選手でもみんな褒めてる人っているでしょ
いきなり打てなくなっちゃうんですね
そういうのはごく普通にあるんです
何々さんだから必ずホームランを打ってくるだろうと思っちゃっても
ホームランのところかもう最下位になっちゃう場合もありますね
彼の点数が 世の中はそんなもんだとよく理解してほしい
因果法則というのは 例えば我々は種を植える
植木鉢に 種を植えたら
適当に水をあげたならば
適当に栄養か肥料ですか
そういうものをあげたならば
適当に日に当たるようにしてあげたならば
適当にそれを面倒を見てあげたならば
虫にも食われなかったならば
芽が出て木になる可能性はあるんです
それでも誰か子供が遊んでるところで
あれで足で蹴っ飛ばしちゃったら
それは死んでしまう可能性もまたあるんです
この突然 アクシデンタルと英語で言うんですね
そういう原因もあります
で せっかく全ての条件そろって
子供の入らないように子供の手に届かないところに植物を植木鉢を置いて大事に守ったにしたっても
突然火事になったところであの植物が死んでしまう可能性もあります
だからどこまでもその不確定ということはあるんだと
そういうことで 仏教の因果論はこの定め論
定め運命論には違うんですとは違うんです
何でも決まってるんだということには反対なんです
そうすると また私は矛盾してるんじゃないんですかね
だから何でも決まってるんだという意見もありますよ
このパラサミャの中で
例えば人間の運命やら全部神様に全部プログラムされて決まってるんだと
それは英語をご存知の方々はディターミニズムというんですね
ディターミニズムというのは
このディターマインという動詞から出てくる言葉で
大体哲学的な言葉はほとんどドイツ語から来るんだから
そういう風になりますけど
決まると いわゆる決定論ですね
で 決定論を教える宗教もあるかもしれません
そこで じゃあ仏教は決定論に反対だから
仏教は決定論者と喧嘩するんですか？と言えば
それは喧嘩しないんです
何でしょうかね 喧嘩しないのは
それはこの決定論 喋る人々は物事のありさまをある角度で見てそう言うんであって
例えば卵があって その卵を温めてあげるんだと
これは鶏の卵であるならば
私は前も言ったように
決して犬も猫も生まれてこないんですね
もう決まってるんですね
ヒヨコが生まれるということは
リンゴの種を植えたところでトマトは食べられませんね
トマトの種を芽を植えて
じゃあリンゴも食べて
ブドウも何でしたっけ？ イチゴも食べたいなと思ったっても
それは無理な話で 植えたのはトマトであるならば
食べるのはトマトなんですね
その法則を見て決定論を積むんで決まってるんだと
それはまたさらに進むんですね
その人々は どうやって進むんですかというと
リンゴの種からリンゴの木と卵のトマトの種からトマトのツルとか出てくるんだと見て
鶏の卵から鶏が生まれて
犬のメスからは子犬が生まれるんだと
で 知ったのはそこまではいいんだけど
そこで人は犯罪は起こしたと
その人はそれは決まってるんですと
あなたは頭が悪いことはもう決まってるんだと
もうなんだかんだもう決まるんですね
それでどんなものにも決定論を持っていっちゃうんです
それで世の中は無茶苦茶になるんですね
そこら辺は違いますと
その人々もある立場で喋ってるのは確かにわかるんだけど
だからなんだかんだ言っても決まってるんだと
我々は幸福になるか不幸になるか
例えば 人が障害を持って生まれる
その決定論主義者がどう言いますかというと
それはもう何か神様の何かお考え方あるでしょうと
もう決まってるんですね
そこでひどい目に遭う時もあるんですね
例えばイラクの戦争の時は
フセインさんが自分が唯一の神様を信じているんだから
唯一の神様が信じてるんだから必ず勝つんだと
アメリカみたいな宗教にいい加減なところのもう人々のことは
コーランという本を読んでみると
ものすごく罰が当たる
怒られることばっかりやってるんですね
豚肉も食べてるんだから
もう救いようないんですね
そこは僕も冗談でつけたんだけど
で とにかく彼の話を聞くと
確実に自分がアッラーを信じているんだから勝すとと思ってたんです
そこで決定論で戦勝して
もうああいうふうな状態になってしまっちゃったんですね
今の状態に 大変残念な状態に
そこら辺 その人々の過ちなんですね
決まってないんです 決まってないんだけど
世の中のことは無茶苦茶でもないんです
全く勉強しないやつ 人々が素晴らしい知識人になるんだということもないんです
勉強したんだからといって知識人になるわけでもないんです
[背景音楽]一度も悪いことをしていない人だからといって
心は聖人みたいに清らかということでもないんです
面白い話があります 自分の国のストーリーですけど
あのお坊さんがこのちょっと午後暇があって歩いていたんだと
いわゆる山腹を行ったり来たり
行ったり来たり それで年取ってるまあおばあちゃんがそれ見ているんですね
見てて考えるのは あのお坊さんはちゃんと瞑想修行しているんだと
で 自分勝手に決めて見ているんです
それでそのお坊さんがそう歩きながらサッと跳んだんですね
ちょっとだけ ちょっとそれを見たんだそうで
見たらそのお坊さん あのおばちゃんこう考えたそうで
もしかするとあのお坊さんがもう修行すごく進んでいて
もう阿羅漢になりかかっているかもしれません
ですから 自分が阿羅漢になってるかないかと
あれで試したんじゃないかなと
これは大変なことで 素晴らしいお坊さんだと聞いてみようと
いて お坊さんのところにいて挨拶して
あのお坊さん あの跳んでみたのを見ましたけど
あれなぜですかと 自分で確かめたく聞いたんです
それでお坊さん 私は歩いていると子供のときを思い出したと
そこで子供も村でガキたちと遊んで
ボールで遊んでいるのを思い出したと
そこでボールが自分のところに飛んできたんだから
自分がそれ飛び上がってボールをよけたんだと
という風に言ったんだと
だからどういうことかというと
この外から見た人は他のことを考えて決めちゃって
で 話も本人がそうじゃなくて
ふざけてただけなんですね
修行したわけでも何でもなくて
妄想しながらふざけてただけですよ
ということで 我々よくそういうふうなこの物事を決めて行動するということはよくあるんです
それ言ったのは ただ外を見て
人が一度悪いことはしていないんだと
だから善人だとは言えないんです
例えば一度も嘘をつけたことがないんだと
だから素晴らしい人だと決めるの早いんです
もしかすると嘘をつくつけなくちゃいけない条件に迫られたことはなかったんだと
それまた自分の国でことわざがありまして
このブソの何ですかっていうか
あの 誠実な生き方と なんとかそういうふうなことわざなんですけど
いわゆる不倫はしないということなんですけど
だから素晴らしい人はないんだと
まああまり綺麗じゃないんだから相手がないという
相手がないだけのことで
だからできなかったということで
全然不倫した経験がないんだからと
素晴らしい人だなと決めるのは早いんだと
そういう我々の国だったら
そういう冗談はいっぱいあるんです
だからそれは国だけの冗談ではなくて
結局真理なんですよね
ですから 美しい人がいろいろ誘惑される
周りから それでいろいろ失敗はする可能性もある
だからといって悪人だと決めるのはまた早いんです
これは男性にしても女性にしても同じことなんですね
すごくアトラクティブな女性だったら
大体男性たちはすごく甘い言葉をかけちゃうんですね
それでまあ それに引きずられる可能性もあるし
同じくまあ結構美男の男だった
男性だったら他の周りの女の人にとってはモテるということはあるし
だからといってとんでもない最悪の人だとは決めるのまた早いしね
なぜならば そういう条件の中でそうなっただけで
心は別にそんなことをしたくてしたくてたまらない状態にいたということにはないんですね
ですから 物事を決めるのは
決めつけるのはやめましょう
やめて心の平和 生き方の平和
このこれはトレランスと言うんですね
寛容的というか 寛容ですかね
トレランスで寛容ですかね
トレレイト いわゆるいろんな考え方を
すごく余裕があって 寛容的で大きな皿を持って生きていることなんですね
仏教というのはそういう宗教なんです
誰とでも戦うことはしませんし
だからといって もうみんな同じ意見持ちましょうとも思ってないし
いろいろ意見があったとしても
それはそれで構いませんし
すごく寛容的で 心は大きくして
戦わずに戦わないで一掃して生きている方法を根本から教えて理解するんですね
ですから 仏教は本当にわかっている人だったら
キリスト教の人々とものすごくうまくいくし
イスラム教の人々とうまくいけるし
他の宗教の人々とものすごく仲がうまくいけるはずなんです
私の学生の時代では いろんな宗教の人々と一緒にいましたから
全然かすかな喧嘩にもならなかったんです
結構宗教の話もしましたし
かなりうまくいくんです
僕はこれは間違っているんだという立場ではしゃべらなかったんです
その場合はみんな友達同士だから
そういう生き方作ってほしいんです
そこで因縁論というのはそういうものなんです
一つの因で 一つの原因で一つの結果が生まれますよというふうには言わないこと
マッチありますね マッチ棒
それは必ずしも火がつけますか？そうじゃないんです
それはこのマッチの薬品を塗っているところに触れたら
適当な厚さで火の玉が出るのであって
そうでないと何のこともないんです
あの薬を水で溶けて溶けてしまう可能性もあるし
あるいは時間経つともう火が出ない状態にもなるし
決まってないんです そういう因果論なんですね
その点でそういうふうに世の中を見なさい
そういうふうに世の中を見ると
どんな意見にも執着しない
取れない心が生まれるんだと
ですから 因果法則を理解することを悟れることなんです
悟りは段階決めてるんです
その心はいろんな意見から解放されて
みんなと何も対立なく仲良くできるような人生に成り代わってしまえば
それは悟りの第一段階なんですね
別にその人は欲ないわけでもないし
怒りがないわけでもないし
そういうのはあるんだけど
別に人とは意見を持って対立はしない
人の意見はよく理解できる
もし皆様の因果法則はこれから勉強なさるならば
自分で勉強してください
もう説明できません 私には
で 世の中のことは何でも理解できるんです
なぜある人は悪人になったかと
なぜある人はよく勉強できる人になったかと
なぜある人はすごい乱暴ですかと
なぜある人はすごいおとなしいですかと
全部わかるんです すぐ理解できる
どんな勉強でもすごく早くできるようになっちゃうんです
それでも抜群に自分の知識やら知恵やら増えて増えて増えていくんです
そういう大学に入らなくたってもいいんです
ただ 家庭で なんていったっけ
家庭の普通の奥さんとして
主婦として生きていたっても
大体女性たちが なんで私の人生はそんなにつまらない狭いところで年取って死ななくちゃいけないんですかと
一体私の人生は何ですかと困ったり
一生懸命困ったりばっかりしていますけど
そうでもないんです その
家庭という小さな環境かもしれませんよ
その中でもそこに世界があるんですから
そのいろんな自分の子供の生き方やら
子供の変化やら 旦那の生き方やら
彼の変化やら 周りのいろんなことを観察していくと
ものすごく立派な人間になってしまうんです
そうはしないんだから
固定観念で それから決めつけて
例えば姑さんはもう悪いんだとか
あるいは自分の子供だけ正しいんだとか
旦那は浮気するんだとか
そういう何か決めて その決めたもう小さな殻の中で生きているんだから
どうせ年取って振り返ってみたら
あれあれ自分の人生は台無しではないかと気がつくだけで
それはもったいないんです
で 目が覚めておくと いろんなもの見えてくるんです
アリを見ていたっても
そこにアリの生き方見えてくるんだから
その中からでもいろんな哲学を作られます
人生論を作られますし
そういうふうにしていただければありがたいと思ってますけどね
じゃあ それからほんの少々だけ仏教の因果論の一部だけ説明します
これから それあの極論 2つあるっていう極論 2つなんです
1番目はサッサンディッティというんですね
英語ではエターナリズムと言うんですけど
意味は物事は常住しているんだと
いわゆる永遠不滅にずっと存在するんだと
物事は 物事でも魂だけでもいい
変化しないんだと 全く同じものがずっと続けているんだという考え方なんですね
うん 適当な日本語の言葉はないと思います
あるはずなんですけど
普通の哲学的な言葉ですから
エターナリズムという
であの まあ仏教には失礼ですけど
仏教の概念で言うとお分かりになるかもしれません
例えば仏性とか如来像とか
菩提心とか そういう考え方はごく普通にみんなの心の中にあるんですね
あるいは魂とかね それは永遠にあるんだと
我々の心の中に 如来心があるんだと
如来の心 と思ったりすると
何か変化しないものはあるという概念なんですね
キリスト教にもあるんですね
この精霊というか霊というかな
スピリットですね そういうのは体が死んでもスピリットというものは死にませんと
まあそれは宗教から例を出しただけなんです
こちらでは哲学的に喋ってるだけで
物事は消えませんと ずっと消えないであるんだと
何かあるんだと 分かりませんだけど
確実に何かがあるんだと思ってる
極論で概念はエターナリズムと言って
それからアサッサタディッティっていうのは虚無主義なんですね
2番目のアサッサタディッティ
物は消えちゃうんだと
そのものの中にずっと引き続けている何か実体のようなものは何もないんだと
虚無主義 虚無主義というか
というニヒリズム もっとわかりやすく言うと
世の中の人間の考え方はあるとないと 2つに分けてみる
ものはあるという人がいて
ものはないという人がいるんだ
そういう 2種類の考え方が世の中にあるんです
大勢の人々はこのあるという概念に入ってるんです
あまりこの科学だけ勉強して
他のこと何も頭の中にない一般人々は
このないという状態にも陥る可能性もあるんですね
その 2つも真理を喋っている教えではないんだと仏教で言ってるんですね
真理はわかってないんだと
嘘嘘言ってるとは言わないんです
ただ 真理はわかってないと
そこでお釈迦様はこう言うんです
人々はものは新しい新しい現象が生まれることをよく見るんだと
見て判断するんですね
例えば 種を植えたら種は死ぬんだけど
やっぱり芽が出るんだから
その代わりに植物が生まれてくるんだから
新しいものは現れちゃうんですね
で 紙に紙の紙 1枚持って燃やしちゃっても
紙は消えたんだけど 灰は残っちゃうんですね
それは他の処分した また他の形にまた残っちゃうんですね
新しい形が生まれる それは事実ですからね
例えば 私はご飯食べたらご飯は消えます
消えるんだけど 完全に消えたわけじゃないんです
違う形に変わって 私の体を作るか
エネルギー統制になるか
それは違う形になるんではないかと
ご飯食べて活動しているんだから
そのご飯は違うものに変わったんではないかと
私はご飯食べた 今喋っている
それでご飯食べたエネルギーは使っている
エネルギーは消えますか？そうでもないし
それは空気 空気にエネルギーは入っちゃうし
皆様の心にも耳にも入るし
心に入るかどうかわかりませんだけど
そこでもしかするとそれなりに心にも入って
頭にも入って いろいろ新しい考え方が生まれる可能性もあるし
それによって皆様の生き方変える可能性もあるし
そうするとご飯は消えたんですか？消えたわけじゃないんですね
それから皆様も他の行動をしているんだから
それからそれからいろいろ
もう永遠にこのご飯を消えたご飯の命がもう続くんじゃないかと
そういうふうに想像できるんですね
それ想像するのは ものの現象の生起 Appearance
現象が生まれる 現れることを見る
そこら辺に強調して考える人々なんですね
まあもうわかりやすく言えば
春になると花が咲くでしょうとかね
秋になるとやっぱり紅葉が出るでしょうとかね
不安も夏になってくるとまあ海水でもできるでしょう
なんて言いますか あの海に行ってね
遊ぶことできるでしょうとかね
休み取れるでしょうとか
そういう新しい生まれる現象は考えている
そう考える人々から見ると
たとえご飯見ても食べて消えるんじゃなくて
それはいろんな形に変化して行き渡っているんではないかと
大体科学の世界もそういうふうに考えているんですね
そうするとものは消えないんだと言えるんです
ものは消えないんだと
そう思っちゃったら じゃあ私は死ぬと
死んで消えちゃったということは言えなくなっちゃうんですね
じゃあさらに哲学は進む
それで私は死んでも じゃあ体は体に物質に行くんだけど
じゃあ心やら考え方やら知識やら
自分の理性やら そういう感情的なものは
それもエネルギーですから
それはそれなりに いわゆる自我意識ですね
自分という意識は別なエネルギーだから
それはそれなりに変化していくんではないかと
それに霊魂と言うし 如来神も言うし
仏像とも言うし もう保身とも言うし
菩提心とも言うし いろいろ言葉で心とも言うし
言葉使っているんです
その世界はお釈迦様はサッサンタディッティ
物事は永遠に存在するという極論であると
それは極論なんです なぜならば
彼らがものは生まれることしか 1側面しか見ていないんだと
言っていることは嘘ではないんだけど
見ているのは 1側面だけですと
で それを置いておく で
ニヒリストの方が物事は教務主義的な物事を見る人は
その人は現象の消えることに哲学するんですね
例えば春になって桜が咲いて
ああ綺麗だなと思ったっても
それは４日間で終わっちゃうんですね
もう何のことなく 葉っぱが出てきて
緑に消えちゃいますから
例えばすごい豪華な料理を作ったっても
ちょっと箸を入れてフォークを入れて
もうちょっと舐めただけで
もう価値観は全部消えてしまっちゃうんですね
瞬間で どんな豪華な建物であろうが
ちょっと火がつけちゃったらもうパッと燃えてしまっちゃうし
どんな立派に我々は生きているそうと思っちゃっても
ちょっと車に少々ぶつかっただけでも死んでしまっちゃいますから
階段で倒れただけで 頭がもう頭蓋骨が割れちゃって
そこでもう大変な 首の骨なんか折れちゃったら
もうそれで死んでしまっちゃうんですね
ちょっと我々の首はちょっとこうやっただけでも死ぬんですよ
そんなにすごいものじゃないんですね
すぐ消えちゃう その人々には物事はもう何のことないんだと
で 例を考えれば 例えばこのスティックですか
これはこの６つ持ってきて
同じ長さの６つ持ってきて
３つは三角にする でこのつけるもう３本は上に立ててつけちゃったら
ピラミッド型のもの出来上がっちゃうんですね
そうするとかなり大きいんですね
ピラミッド型に 例えば 10 センチの石を持ったら
それぐらいの 10 センチの高さのピラミッドが出来上がっちゃうんですね
そうすると それを置くためにはかなりの面積というか
このボリュームが必要な場所が必要なんですね
そこで あ これは大きいんだとか
例えばかなり大きいものを作っちゃったら
この部屋の中に持って入らなくなっちゃうんですね
例えば 3 メートルの 3 メートルの長さのもので作っピラミッド作っちゃったら
この部屋には持って入らなくなっちゃうんです
大きすぎて みんなあれ
これでっかいですねって言うでしょ
でも誰かがあれちょっと外しちゃったら
何のことなくあのボリュームは全部消えちゃうんですね
消えて部屋の中でそれぐらいの材料はいくらでも積み重ねるんですね
そのだったら 大体現象というのはそんなもので
ちょっと形変えちゃったらもうあれなくなっちゃうんですね
人間がすごい場所を使ってるでしょ
生きるためには 大きな部屋がなければ
部屋はいくつかなければとか
えらい場所を食っちゃうんですね
もし車なんか買っちゃったら
ずっと地球の場所はそれでとってるし
一人の人間使う空間というと
もうすごいんですね でもその人が死んじゃったら
これぐらいのになってしまっちゃうんですね
灰になっちゃったら何のことないんですね
それでもう灰を入れる入れ物に入れちゃったら場所を取っちゃうでしょ
あの灰はあちこちばらまいちゃったら
全然何も空間も取れなくなっちゃうんですね
そんなもんなんですね
ものを見ると そこで何を見ても
ああ もうすぐ消えちゃうんだと
同じ現象はまた二度と戻れないんだと
例えば人を見て ああ綺麗で若くていいですねと思っても
その瞬間その人の綺麗さということは消えていっちゃうし
若さがどんどんどんどんどんどん消えていっちゃうんですね
ですから ある人はあんた
今の瞬間は若くて綺麗ですよ
それはあっという間 すぐまあすぐ消えちゃうんだと
そういう風にものの消えることを考える
例えば子供はすごい元気で
朝うちを出ても戻るともうヘタヘタで
もう朝のあの元気はもう消えてるんですね
そういうふうに物事の消えることだけ考えると
どんな現象でももう掴みようがないんです
すぐその現象消えていっちゃうんですね
そこで そればっかり象徴して
例えば 紙があって 紙を燃やして灰にするんだと
どう頑張っても あの灰になった灰は紙にはまた戻らないんですね
そこで灰の中で紙の本質はいくら探しても見つからないんです
紙っていうのはものは進めるし
ものは書けるし いろんな仕事ができますでしょうに
灰はそんな何一つもできない
もう二度とは紙には戻らない
もう消えちゃった 紙は紙としての存在は
違う形をとってない 灰は灰としてですから
いるんだから その灰ももうふっと空気に吹いてしまえば
それでもそれも消えてしまっちゃうし
そこで空気になるんだから
空気の埃になっちゃいますから
全然戻りくはないんです
それの正しい考え方でしょうに
前言ったのは 物事は存在しているんだっていう考え方
今言ったのは 物事は存在しないんだ
もうすぐ消えちゃう 幻覚だと
その人々はアサッサタディッティ
ものは存在しない 実体はないんだと
すぐ物事は消えるんだというニヒリズム
虚無主義を作るんです
それもお釈迦様は極論であると
あまり単純で面白くないというならば
少々難しい内容も言えるんですけど
それも一応極論であると言って
じゃあ極論を置いておいて
正しく真理を語るならば
まあ当然皆様知っている言葉が出てきますけど
あの経典の文章を全部そのまま書きます
マッジェーナ・タターガタ・ワ・ダンマン・デーセーティ
マッジャっていうのは中
中道ではないんです だから日本語で書けないんです
マッジャっていうのはまあセントラルスタンドポイントというか
この立場なんですね 中立的な立場なんですね
中立的な立場でタターガタを
タターガタ 如来はダンマン
法をデーセーティ 説くと
また続くんです これ僕はこのあるお経文は今説明しているだけなんです
全部お経文を申し上げると
サッバン・アッティーティ・アヤム・エーコワント
サッバン・ナッティーティ・アヤム・ドゥティーヨワント
エーテーテー・ウボーアンテー・アヌパガッマ・マッジェーナ・タターガタ・ワ・ダンマン・デーセーティ
ヤデ
ィダン・イマスミン・サティ・ダン・ホティ・イマスミン・アサティ・ダン・ノ・ホティ・イマスミン・イマッサ・ウッパージャヤ・イダン・ウッパジ・イマッサ・ニロダヤ・イダン・ニロッジャティ
でアウィッジャワ・ビッチャー・サンカーラという風にまたまたお経はずっと続けていくんです
ちょっとしたお経のもうほんのかすかな行だけ説明してるだけなんです
マッジェーナというのは中立的な立場を持って
如来はダンマン 法を説く
その教え方はどういう教え方かと次に行きましょう
で なぜかというと このあるという人々は物事を現れることしか考えてないんです
ないという人々は物事を消えることしか考えてないんですね
でも本当はどうでしょうかね
紙は紙でも永遠に消えたことも正しいし
だからといって紙は灰にもなったし
紙はないんだけど灰はある
で だからどっち取ればいいんですか？永遠にあるというならば
灰の中でも紙の性質はあるはずなんですね
例えば紙の中で何か変化しないものがあるんだというならば
その何か変化しないものは灰の中にあるはずなんですね
でも灰は灰で全く別質なものなんです
ですから このエターナリズム
常住論も取れなくなっちゃうんですね
灰の中で紙のもの何もないんだから
じゃあニヒリズム 虚無主義取れますかというと
紙は消えちゃった だから全く完璧に綺麗に消えたんですかというと
そうじゃないんです 灰という新しいものが生まれているんだから
ですから それはどっちでも真理の一部を偏見で見ているだけです
だから仏教は喧嘩しない
あんた方は言ってることは嘘ではありませんだけど
真実ではありません それも矛盾らしいじゃないんです
皆様 嘘ではありませんと言った途端
真実だと思っちゃうでしょ
そうじゃないんです 嘘ではありませんだけど
真実ではありません 堂々と世の中に嘘を言ってる人はいませんから
特にこれ 宗教哲学者たちだから
みんな真面目で真剣なんですよ
嘘は誰も言ってない ヨーロッパの哲学でもヨーロッパの心理学でも嘘言ってるわけじゃないんです
でも 僕らから言っているのは嘘ではありませんが
真実ではないんだと You
are not lying, but it is not the truth. その言葉の中では
仏教のこの立場が見えるはずなんですね
普通の人間だったら あの人嘘言ってませんよと言っちゃったら
言ってることは全部真実になってしまっちゃうんですね
あの人嘘言いませんだからと言っちゃったら
その人ことはもう信じましょうと
仏教はそうは言わない
あの人は嘘は言いませんということは OK
でもだからといって言ってることは全部真実だよというようにならないんです
ややこしいでしょうかね
ややこしくないんです
例えば 私は嘘言わないんだけど
私言ってることは全部正しいというようにならないんです
決してならない なぜならば
私の例えば私はこういうことを書く時でも
文字が間違うわ それから経典から引用してをしたっても
もしかすると言葉を忘れるかもしれませんし
あるいはもう今もこちらの場所を考えてローマ字で書くんだから長い時間取れるし
だからもうカットするでしょうに
ですから 皆様 この行を覚えただけで
そのお経を知ってるんだと言えませんよ
このあるお経の初めに出てくる二行の二行があります
その二行の中にも 4 分の 1 なんです
もっと小さいかな ですから
私は別に嘘をついているわけじゃなくてないんだけど
あの和尚は全部言ってるわけではないんです
そういうことなんです
例えば うちの中で 妹がお母さんにお母さん
お兄ちゃんがいるんですか？と聞く
でお母さんがいきなりいないでしょと言ったり言ったりする
それで妹がそれを信じると
そうすると妹がお兄ちゃんの部屋に行ったところで
ドアを開けちゃったらいるんじゃないんですか
そうすると母が嘘を言ったんですか
母がいないでしょうと言ったんだから
どうなるんですか その場合は
それで妹が言われて お母さんなんで嘘を言うんですか
嘘をつくなと言ってるんじゃないんですか
でお母さん嘘言ってるでしょうと
で喧嘩するかもしれません
どう言えばいいの その場合は
その場合は決して母は子供には嘘は言わない
嘘は言わないんだけど
母が言った言葉は真実ではなかったんです
じゃあそれだと言ったことは嘘でしょうと
嘘じゃないんです 母がそれで判断したんですね
あの男がいるとえらいうるさいし
ものすごい大騒ぎするし
うちの中めちゃめちゃし
だからずっともう 1時間 2時間も全く静かで
ということは どこかに行って遊んでるだろうと母がいろんな条件から考えて判断しただけなんです
それで妹が部屋開けてみたら
もうもうグーグーと寝ているんですね
そういうことです ですから
母が嘘を言ったんではないんです
自分の能力でできるだけの判断をしただけなんです
その判断は新しい事実が発見すると合わなかっただけ
科学の世界も同じでしょ
科学者は今日言うことは明日になると変えちゃう
じゃあ世界一嘘つきは科学者でしょ
そうすると ずっと変えて変えて変えていったんだから
でも科学者は嘘つきじゃないんです
例えば 薬の場合も この薬は素晴らしいんだ
素晴らしいんだとかね
言っていて 後であれは良くないんだと
使ってはいけませんと全部処分したりするんじゃないですか
この細菌もなんとかなんとか薬とかね
処分するようになりました
アメリカで でも今までずっと使っていたんです
今まで正しいんだ 正しいんだ
飲んでもいいんだと言っていて
今今更になってなんで良くないというんですか
昔皆さん覚えてるでしょう
タリナマイという薬のケースがありましたりして
初めはそれはいい薬だとみんな思っていたし
後であれは毒ですよと
飲んではいけないんだと
と思ったりするし 科学の世界
だから科学者は嘘つきですかね
じゃないんです その時は十分なできる判断はしました
後から発見した事実から見ると
あの判断は間違いましたと
ですから我々も人を言う人は嘘を言っているという言って喧嘩する必要ないんです
その代わりに その人の言っていることは正しくない場合は
いえ あなたはこういう事実も知ってますかと
こういう事実から見ると
この意見は違うのではないかと言った方がいいんですね
それは中道的な立場であって
因果法則を考える人の生き方なんですね
ですから 世の中は永延不滅に存在するんだということは
この第１番目の極論で
物事は消えるんだから何も残りまへんとというのは第２番目の虚無主義で
日本では２種類いるんです １
種類が人が死んじゃったら成仏するんだと思っているし
１種類の人間が人は死んじゃったら全部それでパワー消えちゃうんだと
自然に戻るだけでお墓に行くんだと
行ってお墓を拝んだりするんですね
お墓に執着するんですね
行っていくらでもお金払ってお墓を買う
自分がずっとお墓の中にいると思っちゃうんです
そういうふうに２種類がいるんですけど
その２種類も極論なんですね
で マッジマパティパダっていうのは
お釈迦様はすぐに説明するんです
これがあるからこれが生まれる
これが消えたらこれが消えると
いわゆるAがある時はBが生まれる
ある時は生まれる  Aが消えちゃったらBが消えると
そういうふうに教えるんだと
ですから 私にもいろいろ質問するんですけど
みんな あの質問にはほとんどの質問にはもう腹が立つだけで答えられないんですね
全部極論で聞くんですね
輪廻はあるかないかと
心はあるかないかと 心はなんですかと
僕はこれ人間聞く質問じゃないんだと思っちゃいますよ
全部自分で判断して決めつけて
あるかないかで言ってくれと
あるのないと言えない場合はどうするんですかね
お化けはいるかないかと
死んだら生まれ変われるかないかと
そういうのはもう人間が聞く
人間が聞く質問じゃないんです
ものすごいもう何にも事実わからない
ただ 紙 1枚 卵 1個見てヒヨコが出るかないかと言ってくれと言えないんだから
じゃあ紙は 1枚持ってきてください
紙 1枚持ってきて この紙は最終的にはどうなるんですか？説明できますか？必ずしも灰になるんですか？わからないんだから
紙は必ずしも灰になると
誰が言うんですか？そんなことを
いろんな方向へ変える可能性ありますから
もしその紙は 例えば他のいろいろ接着剤やらいろんなものを付けたりして
何か建築材料なんかに使えば
これ何十年も持ちますし
これ保存しておけば それまたそれなりに時間かかっちゃうし
あるいは植木鉢に入れて水なんかかけちゃったら
そこは植物の栄養として吸収されちゃうし
ヤギに あるいはヤギですね
紙食べるのは ヤギにあげちゃったらヤギはあれ食べるし
灰になるくはないでしょう
ヤギが食べちゃったらあれ結構栄養あるんです
日本ではヤギがいないんだからいいんだけど
昔は自分の国ではヤギがいたんですね
あっちこっちみんなかわいいと思って買っちゃうんですね
かわいくて買うのはいいんだけど
服は干せないんだ 服を干しちゃうと
ちょっと見たらもう登るでしょうに
木なんか登って こうやって引っ張って食べるんです
それで紙はもう見たらもうすぐ食べる
もう小さいながら家の中に入ったり
子供たちと遊んだりするんだから
もう花やらもう何だかんでも食べる
ヤギの口はなんか英語でアイアンマウスと言うんです
なんでアイアンマウスと言うんだけど
かんだかんだ植物は死んじゃうんです
牛に食べられたらそれほど死にませんだけど
一番先っぽいつでも食べちゃうんだから
ですから 紙の場合も結構ヤギが食べるんです
ヤギが食べちゃったら
これ灰にならないでしょう
ヤギはあれを食べてフンを出しちゃうと
フンはちゃんとした肥料だから
あのヤギを殺して食べちゃったらどうなるんですかね
そうすると 髪の毛の栄養は人間が食べたことになっちゃうんじゃないんですか？結局
髪の毛じゃなくて紙 1枚は人間の栄養にもなれる可能性があるんです
ですから 僕に聞いたっても
必ずしも紙は灰になるんではないかと
なんか棒でもあったら
金棒なんてあれを頭に引っ張ったってあげたいほどぐらいなんですね
バカな質問するなと 世の中を目を開けて見ろと
だから輪廻があるかないかとかね
成仏できるかないかとかね
あまりにもこの子供も聞かない質問なんですね
子供の質問はすごい賢いんです
大体なぜということだけ聞くんだから
あれすごくいいんです
僕はあれすごく気持ちいいんです
一生懸命答えるんです
その時は すごい難しい質問されますけどね
たまに なんとか何とかあれはなぜですかと
それはなぜ正しいかというと
その子供から見れば 例えばバラの花は赤く
なんであの花が赤いんですかと聞くでしょう
母が答えられないんですね
答えられないのは母の頭が悪いだけであって
子供 ちゃんとした赤いバラの花があるんだから
それはなんとか訳があって赤く
赤く 赤くなったんです
それはなぜですかと聞くんだから
それにはちゃんとした答えがあるんです
大人はそうじゃないんです
輪廻はあるかないか 心があるかないか
成仏するかないかとか
よくもあんな質問するなと
いわゆる未来について質問する
そういうことでしょ？子供は過去について質問する
よく世の中を見てください
子供は過去について質問する
過去は終わったんだから説明できる
例えばヒヨコがいて なぜなぜヒヨコが生まれたんですかと言っちゃったら
それはもうちゃんと 20 何日間きちんと正しい温度で卵を温めて
それからその卵をちゃんと命があったんだからヒヨコになったよと答えられますから
でも大人が卵を持ってきて
この卵は必ずしもヒヨコになるかならないかで聞くんですから
あれほどバカな質問がないんです
大人はみんな未来について質問する
ですから 僕は一番嫌なんですね
大人の質問に答えるのは
全部未来について 未来について語りくはないんです
だからといって未来はいい加減が曖昧で無茶苦茶ですかというとそうでもないし
未来は定めで決まってるんですかというとそうでもないし
そこでいろいろ因縁 条件が揃って成り立ってるんだと成り立ってるんだと
そこは見てみなきゃわからないんだと
ですから 輪廻転生 人が死んでどうなるんですか？と聞く人々に
僕の正しい答えは死んでみろと
そうしなきゃわからないんだから
死んでみればわかるもんで
それは今からそんな困らなくなってもいいんだからね
成仏するかないか それは死んじゃったらわかるもんでから
今から悩まなくなってもいいのに
そこら辺で我々は道が誤るんです
生きる道が そこは仏教を直してあげる
因果法則に戻れと 科学に戻れと
仏教は科学ではないんだけど
科学的それは科学より完璧な科学的サイエンティフィックでもサイエンスではありません
サイエンスというのはすごい狭くて狭くてものすごく面白くないんですね
ものをいじっていることだけだからね
あれつまらないんです
でもサイエンティフィックなんです
うん まあ結構時間はなくなりましたけど
今日はあの床に座らせていいと思います
椅子に座ったらもうあまりにも楽をして寝ていると思いますけど
今の時間になってくると
ですから 足が痛い方がありがたく思ってください
眠くならないんだから
いっぱいあるんで 喋らなくちゃいけないことは
ということは 因果法則ではすべてのものは説明する
未来はではなくて すべてのものは説明する
ですから 仏教は仏教の答えは因果法則という答えなんですね
コーサリチということなんですね
ですから お釈迦様は例えば
たとえ人が悪いことをしたんだからといって罰が当たりますよと
そんなことは言わないんです
例えば 日本でよくみんな知ってるこの仏教だと思っている言葉があるんですね
善因善果 悪因悪果とか
みんなあれ仏教の教えだと思ってるんですけど
そんな冗談じゃないんです
必ずしも善因善果と悪因悪果と
そうすると定めですから
善因があっても 善果が出てくるのはそれなりの条件そろったならばなんです
私は金持ちになる原因全部そろってるんだと
頭もいいし 仕事もできるし
いろいろ新しいものも考えられるし
元気もあるし 体力も余分あるし
もう何でも過ぎているんだと
それから何て言いますか
この投資するお金を持ってるんだと
それで私は全部そろってるんだから大丈夫
全て原因そろってるんだから金持ちになりそうと思って
タバコを一つ吸いながらテレビを見ているんだと
で 金持ちになるんですか
それで なるわけないでしょうに
世界経済情勢は全部知ってるんだと
情報は 状況は 世界経済の
それから経済的な動きの全部予知もできるんだと
どんな株が上がるか どんな株が下がるか
全部もう一応予測できるんだと
それまで大体もう８０パーセントもう的中するんだと思って
それそれであっても金持ちになるの？ならないんだから
それだったら その人はやっぱりそれなりの行動をしなくちゃ
その原因をそろえなきゃ全果が出てこない
そういうことで そんな軽々く言うなと
千因千果 悪因悪果とか
だから結構私とはもう喧嘩になりますけど
すごく偉そうに自分知ってるんだと言って
だから仏教ではね 千因千果
悪因悪果と あんた知ってますけど
漢字も書いてくるんです
たまに僕に 大きなお世話で
なんとか経典にこうあるんだとかね
天台智顗はこうおっしゃったんだとかね
なんとかの仏教の本でこうありましたとか
僕は大きなお世話ですよと言いたいんだけど
そんな軽々く言うなってのは私は言いたい立場なんですね
ものはそんな簡単じゃないんだから
そこでまたお経から少々引用ではなくて
一寸物語を教えます あの超能力ある人々がいるんだと
確かにインドではたくさんいたんです
今みたいなインチキだけではなくて
本物の超能力者は結構いたんです
昔はやることなかったんだから
もういっぱい時間がありましたから
瞑想するんですね 今の人はご飯食べることには時間全部終わっちゃうんですね
ご飯食べて片付けて掃除をして洗濯して
それでもう昼ご飯ですから
それを食べて買い物をして
それから夜のご飯を作って
それで片付いて寝ると
男は仕事も買い物をするために
家賃を払うためにお金が必要ですから
それお金持ってきますよと言ったら
それで １日が終わると
食べることで全部終わっちゃいますね
今の人間っていうのは
えらい科学は発展しているんですね
科学発展して人間に余裕が潰っているんですね
何も余裕がないんだから
そういう矛盾は誰も感じないんですね
のぞみが出たんだから早く行けるんだと大阪まで
そこで１時間儲かるんだと
儲かってるんですか １
時間は １時間忙しくなっただけでしょう
さらに忙しくなって さらに暇がなくなっちゃう
リニアモーターが出たらさらに人々はひどくなっちゃうんです
そこで今はもうみんなもう何て何ですか
あれは通信 用もないのに
今大根より早くコンピューター売れるんです
大根は売れ行きは下がってます
コンピューターは結構売れるんですね
もう人 人 人ですね コンピューターショップは
行ったらもうそれよりは安く
このものすごいんです
あれ 何のために買うんですか？みんな通信のためなんですね
えらい錯覚してるんです
自分の部屋の中で電話線つなげて
世界中の情報を自分が知ってるんだと
部屋の部屋にいながらすぐ何でも情報取れるんだと
自分が世界につなげているんだとえらい錯覚して
人生台無しになるだけなんです
あれ あれで暇がなくなっちゃうんです
もっと暇がなくなっちゃうんです
いわゆる家を出る前に仕事を済ませということになるんだから
会社もそれ使ってるんだったら
あんた夜この仕事をして
朝ちゃんと流しておきなさいと
言っちゃえば徹夜して自分が仕事しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
もし社長がアメリカに行ったならば
一応楽できるのに 社長が帰るまではね
のんびりと仕事を半分中途半端にして
で 社長は向こうから通信でなんとかなんとか資料を送ってくれとかね
なんとかなんとか研究レポートを作ってくれと言っちゃったら
そこをまた一生懸命夜徹夜して作ったりで
また投げつけなくちゃいけないんですね
そんな発達でも何でもなくて
人間のせっかくの２０時間はもう１秒単位で取ってるだけで
でも昔の人々はもう結構暇があったんだから
瞑想して本物の超能力者はいっぱいいたんですね
それは余計な話でしたけど
で 何ですか お釈迦様はこう言うんです
いろんな超能力者がいるんだと
その超能力の人々は 自分の超絶な知恵で人間を見るんだと
人間を見ると ある人が窃盗するわ
嘘をつくわ 泥棒するわ
よこしまな行為をするわ
悪口を言うわという十悪をするんだと
邪見は持ってるんだと
それでもその人は死んじゃったところで
どこに生まれ変わったんですかと見たら
あれ 意外は意外は天国にいるんだと
それ自分の超能力あるんだから
そこでその人 ああ 悪いことをしたっても
結局悪い結果には得られないんだと
天国にあの何とか人が生まれたんだから
私は知ってるんだからというふうに結論作れるんだと
そっちの反対も同じなんですね
すごくいいことをしていた人なんですけど
亡くなったらどこへ生まれたんかとか聞いちゃったら
ああ 地獄に落ちるんだ
落ちてるんだと あれ いいことをしたのに
あの人は地獄に落ちているのではないかと思って
善因には善果はないんだと
悪因には悪果がないんだと言うんですよと
でもお釈迦様はそれはちょっと違うんだと
そんな一個だけ見て決めるなと
これローナパレというお経の名前はローナパレ
ローナパレというのは英語で言えばピンチオブソルトという
ちょっと塩ひとつかみという意味なんですね
塩のひとつかみという名前
タイトルのお経なんです
どういうことかというと
お釈迦様はほんの少量の水を持ってきて
それに昔の塩っていうのは粉じゃないんです
あの石みたいに大きいんです
あの海から自然に作るものだから
今も僕は使う塩はそういう塩なんです
粉のような塩は使わないんです
ですから 結構大きいんですね
それを水に溶いて使うんです
で ほんの少量の水に 1個の塩を持って溶いちゃったら
あれえらい塩辛いんだと
そこで大きなバケツ一杯ぐらい
あるいは川に ちょっと塩を持っていて
湖に持って行って塩を 1個入れてみるんだと
入れても平気で全然塩味しないんですね
湖は そんなもので 人の心のいろんな原因の大きさによりますよと
心のレベルが狭い人がちょっと罪を犯しただけでも地獄に落ちるんだと
でも 湖のような大きなスケールの心を持っている人は
たまたま罪を犯したっても
全くそんなことはひっちゃりで聞きもしないんだと
ですから 簡単に軽々く判断するなと
この超能力者にも言ってるんです
ですから 皆様もそういう仏教の話はもう軽々く判断してしまおうと理解してやろうとは思わない方がいいんです
超能力もないんですから
超能力どころか もう修行する暇もないんですから
例えばこういうことなんです
例えば人が悪いことをしましたと
悪いことしたところで
人死にさせたことがないんです
ないんだけど ああ 悪いことをしまっちゃったなぁ
いけないなぁとか いつでもそれくよくよくよくよくよくよ悩んでるんだと
ああ 気持ち悪いことをしましたとか
ああ嫌だとかね そういうふうに暗く暗く考えると
その人の心そのものが全く暗いそのものになってしまっちゃうんですね
そうすると死んじゃったら当然地獄落ちちゃうんですね
でも した悪いことはたった人しかないんです
そういうふうに 原因結果によって
条件によってもう次は決めるんです
なんかちょっと不公平な法則ではないかと思うかもしれませんよ
ということは たった 1万円盗んだ人が地獄に落ちる可能性もあるし
1,000万円盗んだ人は全然地獄に行くどころか天国に行く可能性もあるんです
どういうことかというと
まあお金がないんだから 1,000万円も盗んじゃったんだけど
まあそれはそれなりに償って
まあ二度とはやりませんだからと
これから頑張って元気で生きてますと
それはちゃんと弁償して
まあ平気で生きてるんだと
元気で健康的で明るく
人があんたそのもう５年前で 1,000万円盗んだんで
盗んだ泥棒ではないか
ああ そうですね その５年前で
私は本当にあれで警察に捕まって
こうこうなって こうこうなって
それから僕はこういうこういうことをして
今はこういう風になっているんだと
すぐ明るくて やってる全然地獄に落ちません
ですから そういう法則なんです
1,000万円盗んだ人は
地獄で 1,000倍倍以上苦しんだりして
1万円盗んだ人は まあそれの10分の1ぐらい
もう1000分の1ぐらいしか苦しまないんですよと
ちょっと大違いです 例えば
例えもっと分かりやすく言えば
1万円盗んだ人は地獄で
あの  1万円盗んだ人は地獄でもう100年苦しんだと
というと  1,000万円の人は1,000年苦しみますかという
それはわからないんです
そういう数値の方程式ではないんです
心の公式に その結果は
この ミス あの 何と言いますか
この塩はどんな水で溶いたかと
大さじ 1杯の水で溶いたかと
水で溶いたかということなんです
世の中だったら すぐ人間のことをこのやってる悪いことで判断したがるでしょう
一回悪いことしたら その人はもう永久的に信頼しないと
そんなことをやっちゃいけないんです
その人はすぐ立ち上がる可能性ありますから
そういうふうなことですから
このなかなかこの物事は運命論でもなく
それから全く不確定でもなく
因縁によって生まれるんだと
と理解してほしいんです
それはカルマにしたっても同じこと
来世にしたっても同じこと
自分が今持っている心の状態でそれを考えた方がいいんですね
ですから この常住論からいうものは消えたら
完璧に消えるんじゃなくて
違う形をとる それも正しいし
だからといって絶対に二度と戻りくはない
消えて新しいものは全く違うもの
灰は灰 紙は紙 何の関係もない
灰を研究したところで
これは和紙でしたか あるいは普通の紙ですか
新聞紙ですかとはわからないんです
灰は灰だから そういう複雑なこともありまして
それからニヒリ즘で言ってることも
それはそれで消えちゃうし
ですから 我々の場合も
人が死んじゃったら全部パッと消えると言ったら
それはちょっとおかしいし
だからといって 私の何か魂のようなものは向こうで生まれ変わって
それは私だ 俺だ 俺だというものはありますかと言って
それもないし それをわからないと言わないでください
紙 1枚燃やしたっても同じことだから
じゃあ私は裏で紙 1枚燃やして
それは灰を全部こうやってすりすりして
それから水 1滴入れて
それのり状態にして持ってきて聞きますけど
皆様に 教えてください
これは冊子の紙ですか？新聞の紙ですか？あるいは段ボール箱の紙です
言えますか？顕微鏡から見ていろんな研究したっていうの
言えませんだから 何も元のアイデンティティを持つものは今のものにはないんです
じゃあ だからといって
この灰は鉄を燃やした灰ですかとか言って
そうではないんです それから種を植えたら
種はもう完璧に消えちゃうんです
芽が出たら 種の跡形もないんです
その代わりに まあミカンやらリンゴやらいろんな果物が出る
じゃあ私は今食べてるリンゴは植えた同じリンゴですよというバカがいるんですかね
でも 輪廻についてそう考えているんですね
どれほどバカバカらしいかというと
リンゴ食べながら これは私が植えたリンゴですよと
冗談じゃないんだ 自分が植えたリンゴの種はもうとっくに遠い昔もう消えてるんです
でも一つは言える あなたは種が植えたんだから
このリンゴはあなた食べてるんだと
ということは リンゴを例えば私が植えたリンゴの木のリンゴは隣の人には食べられないんです
隣の人はヘビ屈持っ持ってきて
このニヒリスターも あなたを植えたリンゴの種は遠い昔
もう 2年前でもう消えちゃったんだと
もう土にもないんだと
もう全くないんだと ですから
あなたには何も証明はありません
何も証拠はない だからこのリンゴは私は食べます
といって食べられますかと
俺は食べられない それはこのうちのリンゴなんです
隣の家のリンゴではないんです
なぜかとこの家の人が植えたんだから
でも証拠になるものは何もない
そういう法則で輪廻転生はするんです
何もいかない この世のからは
だから我々は過去があったんだから今いるんだけど
どう探しても過去で自分がどういう風にいたって
そういうものを見つからないんです
そこら辺はもう考えたって分からないと思いますけど
どうせどうせその辺になっちゃったら
ものすごい原始的に子供より以下の方に心が行きますからね
ですからまあしょうがないんだけどね
まあ一応この紙と灰の例をとことん頭に叩き込んでおいてください
そうするといつか目が覚めるだろうと思います
あのナーガルジュナという先生
偉大なるお坊さんで 昔この紀元先のおっと言ったんですけどね
で ミリンダという王様から
このメランダという歴史的なギリシア系の王様でしたけどね
対話があって これはパーリの中で拠点として残っているし
で そこに輪廻する場合は
何が行くんですかと 聞いたら
ナーガルジュナ先生お坊さんは
いえ 全然何も行きませんと
言ったら ああ そうです
そうすると輪廻した人は全く違うもので
いえ 違うものでもないんだと
じゃあどういうものか
いい 別に同じものでもないんだけど
違うものでもないんだと
説明するんですね 実体魂ってものも何もないんだ
全員不実なもの 例えばこの車なんですね
あなたは王様はどうやって来たんですか？と聞いたら
私は車で来ましたよと
車ってこういう今の車じゃないんです
馬車でしょうね 車で来ましたよと
車って何ですかね？王様に聞きますけど
どっちの方がどっちが車ですか？と
あんた言ってるでしょ？車に来たんだと
車で来た どっちが車ですか？車軸が車ですか？車軸は車軸で車じゃないんだと
じゃあ車輪 車輪は車輪で車輪で車ではない
軸は軸で車じゃないんだと
それで馬をつける いろいろありますね
いちいち聞くんですね
それであれはあれで車じゃないな
じゃああなたの屋根は？屋根は屋根で車じゃないんだと
王様のくせになんで嘘を言うんですか？と
車で来たと言ったんだけど
今車はどこにもないでしょうにと
言って このお坊さんがもう反対疑問するんですね
もうよくもあの王様とお坊さんがお互いに怒らないで討論してたなと思いますけど
言ったらまた言い返しちゃうんですね
すごくこの面白い本ですけどね
言ったら王様はちょっと待ってくださいと
私は嘘を言ってないんだけど
世の中でこの車輪があって
軸があって 屋根があって
車軸があって 馬があって
そういうものは揃ったら車と言うんですよと
これ生命も同じだと 肉があって
骨があって ああだって
これだって 目があって
耳があって ただ揃ったところで人間と呼んでやって
耳が取ってしまえば 目が取ってしまえばただの目ん玉であって何もないんだと
いわゆる色受想行識ですか
色受想行識と五つは揃っているんだから
人間だと呼んでやって
別に人間という何もないんだと
車と同じですと それで王様がじゃあこのお坊さんさらにいじめてやろうと思って
次の質問なんで じゃあ人間でもない
素性というものは何もないんだったら
我々は悪いことしたって別にへっちゃらでしょうと
別に地獄に行くんだとかね
天国に行くんだとか そんな困ったりする心配する必要ないんだと
言ったら じゃあ聞きますけど
あなたはマンゴーを卵マンゴーの種を持ってきて
マンゴー食べて美味しかったんだから
あなたの庭でマンゴーを植えると
植えたところ そのマンゴーは大きくなって
まあ年経ったところで美味しいマンゴーが出るんだと
そこで隣を歩いている人がそのマンゴーを平気で取って食べてるんだと
食べてるとこはあなたの人々が
この嫌いな人々はその人を捕まえて
王様のもの盗んだと あなたのところに捕まってくると
捕まってくると あんたは裁判やろうと思っちゃうでしょ
思ったらその人はこう言うんだと
これは決して王様のマンゴーではありません
王様は昔は何か食べて植えたんだけど
そんなものを私は食べてないんだと
それは今とっくにないんだと
私は食べてるマンゴーは違うんです
王様が植えた種は全く違うんです
だからなんで私を 何て言いますか
調べなくちゃいけないんですかと
話してあげてください
話してみてくださいと言ったら
あなたははいはい分かりました
あなたはもっともらしいことをおっしゃいますね
あなたは私のマンゴーを盗んでない
じゃあ返ってくださいと
送りますかと いえいえ
違いますよと 私はあの人を捕まっきちんと罰を与えるんだと
あれあれ おかしいではないかと
いえ おかしくないんだと
私は種が植えたんだから
新しいマンゴーが違うマンゴーが生まれたんだと
ただの種が植えたんだから
だから私のマンゴーですと
実体がなくても というふうに
この輪廻転生をすりますよと
この因果法則によってあの坊さんが教えたんですね
だから我々はここにいたんだから
死んじゃったら どこかで他の生命は活動し始めちゃうんです
ですから 全く自分でもないんだけど
全く自分と関係ないどこら辺の生命でもないんですね
で  たまによくあるでしょうね
どこかで地震が起きちゃ起こったら
例えばどこまあ千葉県でもいいんだけど
大きい地震が起きちゃったら
この屋根が私の上に落ちるかもしれませんし
私は死ぬかもしれませんし
それで私が死んだのは
この屋根が頭に落っこっちゃったんだからなんですけど
でも原因はどこにあるんですか？遠く遠く起こった地震ですけどね
地震自身なんですか？地震自身だとも言えないんだけど
やっぱり地震が起きたんだから
これを頭に起こっちゃって死んだということなんですね
で これなかったならば
私は平気で元気でいられるし
例えば私は死ぬ原因はここにあるんだけど
遠いところでまた違う原因もまたあるんですね
そういうふうにいろいろ原因が揃って
我々の人生はもう変えていくんです
で もう今日言いたかったことは
まだ原因を説明したかったんだけどね
とにかくできれば輪廻転生のことを少々
この心の中で苦しみはどうやって生まれますかと
苦しみの原因もお釈迦様は因果法則で説明しているんですね
人間に無明があるんだと
無明があるんだから 人間にはいろいろ働きが生まれるんだと
その働きから心の働きが生まれるんだと
この心が生まれると 心と体の構成が出来上がっちゃうんだと
体と構成のことを出来上がっちゃったら
この眼耳鼻舌心が生まれてくるんだと
眼耳鼻舌心が生まれたら
外からいろんなものを見たり
聞いたり 感じたりするんだと
その見たり 聞いたり 感じたりするものについてで
この息が生まれてきて
それに渇愛が生まれてくるんだと
いいものには執着が生まれると
嫌いなものから逃げようというエネルギーが生まれてくるんだと
それで物に依存するんだと
物に依存しちゃったら
人間は物に追っ掛けられて
さらに行動するんだと
さらに行動することによって
また新しく新しく生まれて
また新しい同じ苦しみを繰り返すんだとというふうな１２因縁の教えがある
それは苦しみの循環を説明しているんです
仏教は苦しみのことをよく教えますから
いつでも苦しみ 苦しみ
その１２因縁はかなり使っているんです
かなり使っているんだから
人々はえらい誤解しているんです
因縁論というのは 無明から行が生じるという
あれは縁起説だと まあえらい誤解しているんだけど
縁起説っていうのはかなり幅広く大きいんだけどね
あれは苦しみの原因は説明している一つの応用編だけなんですね
で そこで 我々には無明というものがあるんですね
無明というのは物事を理解していない状態なんですね
ですから 別に大した状態じゃないんです
ごく普通な状態なんです
それで何かしなくちゃいけないって
我々の心の中でエネルギーが生まれちゃうんですね
いつでもあるでしょ 心の中に
いつでも何とかしなくちゃ
これは行というんですね
サンカーラ いわゆるもうなんかこの中で何かしたい
何かしたい 何かしたいと
で それによって我々は考えたりするんですね
それによって行動するんですね
行動するといろいろ苦しみが生まれてくる
どこから生まれてくるんだということ
とにかく何かしたい 何かしたいと
それで何かするとどうなるんですかというと
さらに何かしたくなっちゃうんです
そういうシステムで 我々の苦しみはもうずっと続く
死ぬ時でも何かしたいという気持ちは消えないんですね
なんとかならないんですかと
いつでもそんな状態なんですね
それから まあそれまあ
そう言ったって分からないでしょうね
すごい難しいんだから
で 因果法則っていうのはこういうふうに考えていけない A
があってBが生まれる B
があってCが生まれる C
があってDが生まれる D
があってEが生まれるんだと
順番に考えてほしくないんです
例えば男がいて 女がいて
そこで子供が生まれるんだと
子供は赤ちゃんで それから子供になって
それからこうなって それから老ようになって
それから年寄って それからこうなって
これからこう死んじゃうとかね
そういうふうに順番があるんですね
因果法則っていうのは
いつでもそんなもんでもないんです
これは私はシーケンシャルプロセスと勝手に言葉をつけてますけど
シーケンス現象から現象
AからBが生まれるんだと B
からCが生まれるんだと
それまあ分かりやすく
私は石を持って流す 人の窓ガラスに当たると
で 窓ガラスは割れると
それで人のうちの人は怒ると
怒って私に喧嘩をすると
私はむちゃくちゃ向こうしゃべるんだけど
何にも理解しないんだと
それでさらに腹が立って
その人は警察に行くと
それいろいろ そういうのはシーケンシャルなんですね
シーケンシャルの場合は
一つが終わってから新しいものが生まれるんです
私の手から石が離して行ってから窓ガラス割れる
割れたらそこで石の仕事は終わると
終わってからそのうちの人が怒ると
割る 割れる前には怒りません
誰もそれで怒りませんから
ですから 子供なんかが野球球とかいろいろ持ってるんだから
怒る人はいないんだから
あるいはあなたはこの球を投げて遊んだならば
窓ガラス割れる可能性ありますから
この野郎と怒る人はいないんです
何やってるんですかと
それは怒らない それはシーケンシャルのプロセスと
で 原因が消えなくても結果が生まれる場合もありますね
あり得るんですかね 原因はまだまだあるんですけど
結果もある それはすごくややこしいところなんですけど
それまあ簡単なことなんですよ
で 例えば水を持ってきてくださいと言ったら
ガラスに水を持っていかなくちゃいけないんですね
水だけ持ってこいと言ったって
それは無理でしょう 水はあるのは入れ物があるだからなんですね
入れ物なく水はいることはできないんです
空気みたいに そうすると空気は持ってきてくださいと言わなくてもいいんです
水は持ってきてくださいと
ここに水があると それは結果なんですね
でも原因もここにその同時にあるんですね
ガラスもあると それでガラスが割れた瞬間で
水もあの姿を消さなくちゃいけないんですね
もう飲めなくなっちゃうんです
で 光があると この光が同時に電気がなければ存在しないんですね
同時にいなくちゃいかないんです
それはもうパラレルプロセスなんですね
その両方もあるんです
因果説は難しくなっているのは
この因果説はこのシーケンシャルプロセスもパラレルプロセスも両方いっぺんに使っているんです
ですから よくみんな勉強するんですよ
何年もかけて で 最終的には分かりませんと終わります
そこで自分好き勝手に好き勝手に仏教をしゃべるんですね
せっかく勉強しましたから
こうですよ あれは全部でっち上がって
もう自分勝手にしゃべるもので
両方分かっておかないと
僕は今日できればそのシーケンシャルパラレルの方法を教えようと思う
もう時間もなくなりましたので
ということは 我々は全部今も持っています
この輪廻する無明も今も持っている
で 無明から行が生じるというと
もうもともと心があるんですね
心に無明があるんだから
体に無明があるわけじゃないんだから
ですから 心がなければ無明は存在しないんですね
いわゆる心という意識の働きがなければ
そこで行ってなんですかと言えば
心で何とかしたいということだから
そうすると一緒にやるんですね
無明もあって 同時にだから何とかしようと同じ
同じ瞬間でそれも生まれちゃうんですね
一緒に生まれるんです
一緒に生まれるんだから
原因結果とは普通の人は理解しないんです
だから もともと神がいて
神は全部作ったんだというのは
その同時進行わからない
理解してないわけなんです
やっぱり最初は誰かが作っておかなきゃダメですよと
あれはシーケンシャルプロセスなんですね
最初は誰かが神でもいいし
お化けでもいいし 鬼でもいいしで
もう生命は作ったんだと
それからは一旦作ったんだから変化しているのは分かりますよ
最初は宇宙は誰かが作らなくちゃいけないんだと
で そこはみんなシーケンシャルプロセスなんですけど
人間がおかしいっていうことは
それだったら神も最初は誰かが作らなくちゃいけないんですね
そこは考えないんですね
いえ 神は永遠にいるんだと
それだったら我々にも永遠にいられるのに
形いくら変えても そういうことで仏教は創設論は全くもうおかしいんだ
あれは全くおかしいんですね
このその人がこう言うんですね
例えば卵があるんだと
卵があるのはニワトリがいたんだからでしょうに
このニワトリがいたのは元の卵があったんだからでしょうにと
じゃあ卵は先かニワトリ先かと言ってくれと
言ったら僕らに言えないでしょ
卵があったら先にニワトリがいるんだから
ニワトリいたら先にまだ卵あるんだから
ですから その人こういう
だから最初は誰かが作らなくちゃいけないんだと
卵かニワトリかどっちかが
誰かが最初に卵かニワトリか作ったら
それからはもう順番は分かりますと
簡単に ですから最初はアダムとイブとかなんとかなんとかどうかもアーディプルシャですね
ヒンドゥー教だったら
最初に人が作ったんだ
作られたんだと言ってるんですね
あれはシーケンシャルプロセスだけ考えて
それも目に見えるものだけ見て言ってるものであって
でも同時にも進行するんです
ものが あのコイルを巻いて
一つのコイルを巻いて
その中に磁石を通してみると電流が生まれるでしょう
磁石を通ってから電流生まれるんですか？通ると電流が生まれるんだから
だから磁石が通ることと電流が生まれることは同時なんですね
だから原因もあって 結果もその時もあるんです
ですから 我々は無明があって
それから行があってと言ったっても
無明がある時でも心もあるし
で それから心が生まれるんだと言ったって
もともと心があったし
心があったんだから身体もあるのは当たり前であって
色から名色が生まれるんだと言っても
前々も体も頭もあったし
そういうところでややこしいんだから
このブッダ・ゴース先生さえ因果法則は説明しようと思ったところで
私の頭はもうまあ海に落ちたような感じで
もうキリがなく もうどうしようもないんだと
とにかくかすかに頑張っていますよというふうに
これぐらいのもう長い長い因果法則の説明書いてるんです
まあそういうことでもわからないということはわからないんですから
しょうがないんだけど
そういう大変なあのまあ整理しようと思ったらわからなくて難しいんですけど
でも我々のわかる一部があるんです
物事は決めつけるなと
あなたは悪人だ あなたは善人だ
あなたが言ってることは間違ってるんだ
あなたが言ってることは正しいんだとか
で ニワトリ 卵から必ずしもニワトリが生まれるということは我々わかりませんと
紙は必ずしも灰になるということは我々はわかりませんと
それなりの原因があったらそれなりの変化があるんだと
というところまでは理解できると思います
そういうふうに世の中にとっても
この一元論だけ捨てましょう
神に作られた 仏様に作られたとか
一元論を捨てて いろいろ複雑ですよと
というぐらいの理解あれば大変結構だと思います
長い間すいません どうもありがとうございます